[Music]
but throughout his career
vermont senator bernie sanders has explained
the inevitable downsides of
massively increasing the power of the state over the
individual
iván sánchez by jádson gold mines wind
though there were days
sanders at the time identified himself as
a socialist  radical who admired the
achievements of fidel's cuba
sandinista nicaragua and the soviet union until the
fall of the berlin wall
[Music]
during his candidacy in vermont in the
1970s
sanders wanted a maximum
tax rate of 100 percent
arguing that no one should  earn more
than a million dollars
sanders wanted to prevent
companies from moving from their home communities he
said that the solution to
protect workers was to create a
national law that would make the
main means of production
state-owned he was in favor
that the government took possession of
public services, banking and
large industries without compensation  tions
for neus investors or shareholders
shortly after he was
elected mayor of burlington
vermont in 1981
sanders told a group of
charity workers that he did not believe
in charity as only the government should
provide social work to those in
need
although today  today he
was a social democrat he has
become a millionaire he
supports the healthcare system through a
single taxpayer public education
for all and a $15 minimum wage
[Music]
although es anders has strayed his ideas
for american politics from the
model of  nicaragua cuba and the
soviet union to the models of denmark
finland and sweden something like this has
remained constant in all these cases he
has misled his followers about
what really happens in these countries
[Music]
in the water
ready young man when sanders was  mayor
of berlin is declining promised that his
city of safi would do the embargo of the
administration of r  eagan against
nicaragua and the sandinistas
it should be noted that nicaragua and the
sandinistas had overthrown a
us financed dictator and
instituted a revolutionary socialist government
in 1985 sanders traveled to nicaragua to
attend the celebration of the sixth
anniversary of the revolution
in uruguay surrounded by  reporters at the
airport upon his return
sanders was excited about what
he had seen in nicaragua
sanders praised the sandinista leadership
and president daniel ortega
praised the seizure of private farms and
businesses
what anders did not mention was that
by 1985 the  international watchdog groups
had already exposed
significant human
rights violations by the
sandinistas a 1981 report by the
inter-american commission on
human rights revealed mass executions and
persecution of indigenous peoples and
only two years before sanders' trip
the magazine  'time' reported that one hundred  os of
citizens disappeared every month at the hands
of the sandinistas
uruguay recommended by winehouse enters
david wright bieber and ex lowry sanders
accused the us government and
media of conspiring to
hide the successes of socialism
its funny
and the sandinistas stayed in
power for five years  more after the
visit of sanders and the
permanent commission of human rights of
nicaragua to document and more than 14,000
cases of rape torture and murder
during his tenure
[Music]
yes
when sanders was still mayor of
burlington he traveled to cuba in 1989 with the
hope of  meeting with fidel castro
however he had to settle for the
mayor of havana by then
castro had already seized private companies and
plantations he had already arrested
artists created
information squads to monitor and arrest
dissidents and had forced
homosexual citizens and other
undesirables  to work in labor camps
but it was tr  Ansparent about his
need to limit individual rights in order
to ensure the
rights of the community he understood that
to guarantee the success of a socialist government he
had to contain the freedom of the
press he
said that he could not tolerate dissidence in
the media since unity in the people
it was essential
we see teams but sanders did not
agree with castro he thought that the
american press was in the same
danger because it was controlled by
politicians and interests of big capital
johns yves saint web today the
cuban government censors the internet
prohibits public demonstrations of
affection between gay couples and
imprisons citizens for criticizing
the government
and it was a blood test bordering on
best building
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1988 three years before the fall of
the soviet union
sanders traveled to russia the day before he
left  he married his
second wife
james it was a trip with double purpose
to which he called a very strange honeymoon
andres formalized the relationship between
burlington and its russian sister city
jaroslaw and praised the social and
cultural achievements of the communist government
on the way back once again a
journalist confronts him about the
report made by the  associated press
speaking of jaroslaw 2's deplorable and unhygienic food shortages and
living conditions
and then said he was impressed by
the transparency with which
soviet officials accepted the
housing crisis
similar to the american
sanders also appreciated crisis  the sincerity
of the Soviets on other issues and
believed that American politicians
had a lot to learn from the communist system
[Music]
i
rivero
[Music]
after an unsuccessful campaign as
governor of vermont in 1986 around the
time of the fall of  the soviet union
sanders set his sights on higher office
edwards renewed himself  as a
social democrat and won a seat in
congress
today sanders opposes the
comparisons made between his
policies and those of the andinistas or
castristas
the swing what has not changed is the
unwillingness of sanders to accept
political reality and  economy of
those countries to which it points as a
model scandinavia is an
important precursor of free
market capitalism in the list of human freedom
in 2018 of the libertarian institute
fraser norway denmark and finland
ranked higher than the us and in
2015 the danish prime minister  contradicted
the claims of sanders
debut life one thing
else underlined
the being an expansion theme of world
food viewed denmark if it offers
expansive social benefits
including single
payer health care free education and months of
paid family leave
the
busti theme presents a fun and  don't
forget to
play danish citizens also pay 25%
in imp  purchase taxes
and vehicle excise taxes reach 180
percent but tax revenues
in nordic countries are not enough
to cover all their
already unsustainable social programs in their current form
sweden is raising the
retirement age and privatizing part of its
system  healthcare in finland
coalition rulers
recently resigned after failing to
pass reforms they saw as
crucial to staving off financial ruin
denmark is raising its
retirement age to 73 and cutting spending and
taxes such
as no water and no competitions with you'
se taxis for  disqus
sanders also points to norway as a
model a country whose massive
oil production subsidizes the
social benefits of a population 62 times smaller
than that of the us never recognizes the
fundamental differences between
nordic countries and america or the
real costs of policies that  Álava
I want to offer even more general
benefits  more expensive than those in scandinavia and believes
that wealthier taxpayers
can pay the bills
sanders has proposed that the government
take over the health sector of
about 18% of gross domestic
product at a cost of 32 billion
dollars for 10 years wants to increase
social security benefits offer
free college education and
give the state new powers to
end climate change through
the new green deal policies
that would add at least 50
billion more to the budget
in order to focus their micros a lot of
work including their  songs all
this to continue the pattern that
has been going on for decades where
decentralize authority ignores all the downsides
and massively increases the
size of government
martin
transformers
we can transform control so
while americans consider
whether they should join the second part
of politics  sanders revolutionary
too  they should consider if this time it
will be different
water
how was it
[Music]